the World Health Organization may be
facing growing International pressure
over its newly released coronavirus
report but here in Wuhan where the
pandemic started people are pleased with
its findings
the who has Authority Western countries
kept accused in China of causing the
pandemic this report shows China is
innocent
I believe the conclusions in the who
report but I think it came out too late
China has suffered a lot from the virus
it shows China is not guilty on Tuesday
the UN agency released a 120-page
document detailing the results of a
month-long mission to China to study the
origin of covet 19. the team concluded
the most unlikely source of the virus
was a bat or other animal and the least
likely was a leak from a Wuhan
government lab the report also thanked
the Chinese government for facilitating
the visit
China has overcome difficulties to
conduct joint research with the who our
goal is to reflect our openness and
transparency but critics say the mission
was anything but open and transparent
Chinese government officials curated and
tightly controlled the visit chaperoning
the experts at all times and controlling
what information they could access
Jamie Metzel says Beijing also vetoed
participants on the mission he drafted
an open letter signed by two dozen
experts calling for a new international
inquiry into China it wasn't an
investigation at all a two-week study
tour with very limited access to records
samples and Key Personnel is not an
entire waste of time but it's not even
remotely close to being the kind of full
and unrestricted International forensic
investigation which we need the US and
13 other countries have signed a joint
statement raising concerns about the
report
who director General Tedros at Honda
Gabriels issued his strongest criticism
of China to date saying raw data was
difficult to access and the Wuhan lab
League Theory required more extensive
assessment the who says they never
expected the mission to produce a
definitive answer about the origin of
covid-19 and a second phase of research
is required but as International
criticism builds over China's role in
the study they may find that Wuhan
becomes increasingly like this former
seafood market blocked off and
impossible to access Katrina you Al
Jazeera Wuhan